so I've been searching for my interviews
quite a bit lately oh yeah Maryann's hmm
what no I'm talking about when I work
stop it
I am a hard-working disciplined
individual you love me more than me the
point I'm trying to make is that
sometimes the muse doesn't come in fact
most of the time the news doesn't come
right I mean muses are depicted as these
beautiful fairy like creatures that will
sprinkle magic dust and everything will
be amazing
in reality muses are like pot head couch
surfers who drink beer and eat pizza
while you sit and do all the dirty work
you just have to keep plowing away until
she says okay okay I see that you're
serious I'll be there in a second
they say quality over quantity and I
think it's a massive amount of quantity
with a deliberate focus on improvement
leads to the knowledge and experience of
how to make quality like I feel a lot of
pressure about what I make what if it's
not good enough what if it's not my bed
maybe I should hold off maybe I should
start surgery tomorrow or or next year
or never even if you feel uninspired
even if you feel like everything you
make is absolute crap just keep going
just keep working hard and focusing on
improving yourself on a consistent basis
don't use the muse or the lack of as
your excuse for slacking off or not even
trying at all a lot of people get
discouraged when they hear what it
really takes to become great and you
know what good that means they weren't
really wanting to be great in the first
place I mean that's like saying oh I
want pizza go get some minutes in the
kitchen yeah but then like I'd have to
heat it up and then like use my arms to
hold it and then use my mouth to bite it
and chew and swallow numerous times I
don't have that kind of time or energy
see you next Monday stay awesome Gotham